if you were to kind of
look back at 2020
and maybe broaden it out to future
pandemics
that could be much more dangerous what
kind of response
how do we fail in a response and how
could we do better
so the gain of function research is
discussing
which you know the the question of we
should not be
creating viruses that are both
exceptionally contagious and
exceptionally deadly to humans
but if it does happen perhaps the
natural
evolution natural mutation is there
interesting technological responses
on the testing side on the vaccine
development side
on the collection of data or on the
basic sort of policy response side
or the sociological the psychological
side
yeah there's all kinds of things and
most of what i've thought about and
written about and again discussed in
that long
bit with with sam is dual use
so most of the countermeasures that i've
been thinking about and advocating for
would be every bit as effective against
a zoonotic
disease a natural pandemic of some sort
as an artificial one
the the risk of an artificial one even
the near-term risk of an artificial one
ups the urgency around these measures
immensely but
but most of them would be broadly
applicable and so i think
the first thing that we really want to
do on a global scale
is have a far far far more robust
and globally transparent system of
detection
and that can happen on a number of
levels the most obvious one
is you know just in the blood of people
who come into clinics
exhibiting signs of illness and there
we are certainly at a point now with
where at with relatively minimal
investment
we could develop in clinic diagnostics
that would be
unbelievably effective at pinpointing
what's going on
in almost any disease when somebody
walks into a doctor's office or a clinic
and better than that um this is a little
bit further off
further off but it wouldn't cost tens of
billions in research dollars it would be
you know a relatively modest and
affordable budget
in relation to the threat at home
diagnostics that can
really really pinpoint you know okay
particularly with respiratory infections
because that is generally almost
universally
the mechanism of transmission for any
serious pandemic
so somebody has a respiratory infection
is it one of the
you know significantly large handful of
rhinoviruses coronaviruses and other
things that cause common cold
uh or is it influenza if it's influenza
is it influenza a versus b
um or is it you know a small handful of
other more exotic but nonetheless
sort of common respiratory infections
that are out there
developing a diagnostic panel to
pinpoint all of that stuff that's
something that's well within our
capabilities that's much less
a lift than creating mrna vaccines which
obviously we proved capable of when we
put our minds to it
so do that on a global basis
and i don't think that's irrational
because the best prototype
for this than i'm aware of isn't
currently rolling out
in atherton california or fairfield
county connecticut or some other wealthy
place
the best prototype and i'm aware of this
is rolling out right now in nigeria
and it's a project that came out of the
broad institute
which is as i'm sure you know but some
listeners may not is
kind of like an academic joint venture
between harvard and mit
the program is called sentinel and their
objective
is and their plan and the very well
conceived plan a methodical plan
is to do just that in areas of nigeria
that are particularly vulnerable to
zoonotic
diseases making the jump from animals to
humans
but also there's just an unbelievable
public health benefit from that
and it's sort of a three-tier system
where clinicians in the field
could very rapidly determine do you have
one of the infections of acute interest
here either because it's very common in
this region
so we want to diagnose as many as things
as we can at the front line
or because it's uncommon but
unbelievably threatening like ebola
so frontline worker can make that
determination very very rapidly if it
comes up as a we don't know
they bump it up to a level that's more
like at a fully configured doctor's
office or local hospital
and if it's still it we don't know it
gets bumped up to a national level
and that and it gets bumped very very
rapidly
so if this can be done in nigeria and
it seems that it can be uh there
shouldn't be any inhibition for it to
happen
in most other places and it should be
affordable from a budgetary standpoint
and based on sentinel's budget and
adjusting things
for things like you know very different
cost of living larger population etc
i did a back of the envelope calculation
that doing something like sentinel in
the u.s would be in the low billions of
dollars
and you know wealthy countries middle
income countries can't afford such a
thing
lower income companies in income
countries should certainly be helped
with that
but start with that level of detection
and then layer on top of that other
interesting things
like you know monitoring search engine
traffic search engine queries
for evidence that strange clusters of
symptoms
are starting to rise in different places
there's been a lot of work done with
that
most of it kind of like academic and
experimental but some of it has been
powerful enough to suggest that this
could be a very powerful
early warning system there's a guy named
bill lampos at university college london
who basically did a very rigorous
analysis that showed that symptom
searches reliably predicted coveted
outbreaks in the early days of the
pandemic in
given countries by as much as 16 days
before the evidence started to crew at a
public health level
16 days of forewarning can be
monumentally important
in the early days of an outbreak and
this is
you know a very very talented but
nonetheless very resource constrained
academic project imagine if that was
something that was done
with a norad like budget yeah yeah so i
mean
starting with detection that's something
we could do radically radically better
so aggregating multiple data sources in
order to create something
i mean this is really exciting to me the
possibility that i've heard
inklings of of creating almost like a
weather map
of pathogens like uh basically
aggregating all of these data sources
scaling
many orders of magnitude up at home
testing and all kinds of
testing that doesn't just try to test
for the particular pathogen
of worry now but everything like a full
spectrum of things that could be
dangerous to the human body
and thereby be able to create these maps
like that are dynamically updated on an
hourly basis
of the of how viruses travel throughout
the world
and so you can respond like you can then
integrate just like you do when you
check your weather map
and it's raining or not of course not
perfect but it's very good
predictor whether it's going to rain or
not
and use that to then make decisions
about your own life
ultimately give the power information to
individuals to respond
and if it's a super dangerous like if
it's acid rain versus regular rain
you might want to really stay inside as
opposed to risking it
and that just like you said if
i think it's not very expensive relative
to all the things
that we do in this world but it does
require
bold leadership
you